last night president Trump hung out with
Tucker Carlson and the rest of the GOP
field debated in Milwaukee I am going to
sum up almost three hours of chatter
across two separate broadcasts in about
60 seconds
the vague ramaswamy helped himself the
most by doing well as an unknown
candidate Mike Pence slightly exceeded
expectations which were low Ron DeSantis
met expectations which were moderate
Chris Christie lobbed a few zingers but
they didn't land nearly as well as they
did last time
among the lower polling candidates Nikki
Haley and Tim Scott also met
expectations and also did not move the
needle among the barely polling
candidates former Arkansas governor ASA
Hutchinson exceeded expectations
inasmuch as he did not to child on stage
and soft on abortion Doug burgum proved
himself to be the single worst candidate
in the race by virtually every measure
and also somehow perhaps the most
likable
they all did fine
but in a race like this
fine
just isn't good enough
not even close
not one of the candidates managed to
break out in such a way that would
threaten the front runner Who currently
leads his most popular rival by more
than 40 points
which means after all that
that Trump won the night without even
showing up I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles
kw-l-e-s I've got a great good Rancher
story in just a moment goodranchors.com
use code Knowles today
we'll talk about the debate there are a
few moments I want to talk about then I
want to talk about a more important
story which is that political dissidents
are being rounded up in this country for
nothing my friend Jenna Ellis has been
arrested and booked and had a mug shot
taken of her in Fulton County Georgia
for simply being the lawyer to the then
president of the United States she's an
actual political prisoner who's now out
on bond she's going to be coming on
whenever we can connect with her we're
going to get Jenna on here this will be
the exclusive first interview since
she's gotten out of jail uh so we'll
we'll have Jen in just a moment first
though we'll get through this debate
uh I enjoyed the debate it was
everything I hoped for which is the
candidates all sort of sniping at each
other
most of my predictions came true I
wasn't terribly surprised by anything in
the debate the big surprises to me were
the vague did a little bit better than I
expected not much better but he a little
bit better I already had Fairly high
expectations for him DeSantis did a
little bit worse than I expected his
answers were all great his record is
great he's a great guy I personally
really like him the reason I say he he
underperformed or at best I would say
maybe met the expectations which had
been moderated down from the high
expectations at the launch of his
campaign is because he kind of
disappeared
he was at the center of the stage of the
of the non-trump candidates he he was
the main guy
and he didn't he didn't really land a
big punch
worse yet he wasn't even really attacked
by his Rivals so he just wasn't the
center of attention the attention was
focused much more on Vivek or on Mike
Pence oddly enough or a little bit on
Chris Christie so it
it didn't move the needle for him and he
needs the needle to be moved because he
keeps slipping in the poles
again I've said from the beginning I
don't really blame DeSantis for this I
think he was in an impossible position
from the beginning I think there's a
line that Julius Caesar said when he
crossed the Rubicon which is Alia yakta
EST the die is cast that the
circumstances now are such that
history is going to unfold in in a
particular way because of just how the
whole thing's been set up in the case of
Crossing the Rubicon it was going to be
violent conflict between forces in Rome
in the case of trump running for a
non-consecutive second term it meant
that anyone who ran against Trump was
going to be seen as the
I don't know the anti-trump candidate
who they were going to attract the never
trumpers they were going to raise the
ire of the people who were still loyal
to Trump even if DeSantis is the best
Governor ever he's Trump 2.0 3.0 bigger
better faster stronger and maybe let's
say all of that were true just the
circumstances of the race and the high
expectations he had from everyone who
wanted an alternative to Trump meant
that he was almost certainly never going
to live up to those expectations and if
I were the DeSantis campaign I would say
this is panic time because what we've
been told about the polls from the
beginning is yeah Trump is leading by a
lot but just wait until DeSantis
announces once he announces then it's
all going to change then he announced
and what happened Trump's lead increased
but they said well forget about the
polls it's Silly Season no one's paying
attention just wait until the debate
DeSantis is going to totally crush it at
the debate
but Trump didn't show up to the debate
so he didn't get his chance to land a
punch on Trump as it stands now I'm not
convinced Trump is ever going to show up
to a primary debate
in fact some of the other candidates
seem to to get more of the spotlight so
we'll see how the polls move after this
debate I'm I'm not convinced they're
gonna they're gonna improve for DeSantis
and so the question for for the donors
and for the campaign staff is
what are we waiting for everything we've
been told to wait for and then it's all
going to change that hasn't happened so
I'm not saying DeSantis is totally dead
I don't think he's totally dead but he
has got to radically shake up what he is
doing
what he is doing right now is losing in
a very gradual dignified way and
allowing other candidates to to jump up
a
I guess the best performance of the
night inasmuch as he went from nothing
he went from a complete unknown to now a
prominent American political figure was
the vague and and he was very very bold
I mean Vivek came out and had the
audacity to say on the stage that he was
the only candidate not bought and paid
for I'm the only person on the stage who
isn't bought and paid for so I can say
this the climate change agenda
the climate change
I've had enough already tonight of a guy
who sounds like Chachi BT standing up
here
and the last person in one of these
debates Brett who stood in the middle of
the stage and said what's a skinny guy
with an odd last name doing up here was
Barack Obama and I'm afraid we're
dealing with the same type of
amateurs tonight
it's so easy that you caught at the end
but Vegas well then give me a hug and he
goes on and he says if I'm like Obama
then great give me a hug you'll help
elect me just like you helped elect
Obama which was a good it would it was a
good hit from Christy Christy hit Vivek
on his weakest points which is he sounds
very slick and he's young and he he did
use a line from Obama so Christy got his
usual Zinger in there but it didn't land
in the way that that it landed on Rubio
he was able to destroy Rubio on on
basically the exact same attack
the chat gbt line against Vivek was the
same thing as the here's the robotic
canned 30-second speech line of attack
against Marco Rubio it didn't really
work on Vivek though the vague
who knows maybe he was a little too bold
in the performance maybe that turned off
some more moderate voters some some more
ordinary voters just in the same way
that it excited more of the online
Millennial type of
GOP base
but that boldness is paid off for Vivek
every step of the way
we're all talking about him tonight all
the fire last night on that stage was
aimed at him
for fortune favors the Bold
you know if you don't if you don't take
any big risks as as a candidate who is
way down in the polls then you really
don't have any shot you're just going to
be a very pleasant amiable loser you're
gonna you're gonna be a really
well thought of put together respectable
number two uh the the next big fiery
moment of the debate was when Nikki
Haley who also did fairly well
given that her the expectations from the
polls were very very low
I think she sort of helped herself uh
Nikki and DeSantis and Mike Pence all
started sniping at each other over
abortion
can't we all agree that we should ban
late charm abortions
can't we all agree story that we should
encourage adoptions can't we all agree
that doctors and nurses who don't
believe in abortion shouldn't have to
perform them can't we all agree that
contraception should be available and
can't we all agree that we are not going
to put a woman in jail or give her the
death penalty if she gets an abortion
can't we have a minimum standard in
every state in the nation that says when
a baby is capable of feeling pain and
abortion cannot be allowed you got to do
what you think is right I believe in a
culture of life I was proud to sign the
heartbeat Bill what the Democrats are
trying to do on this issue is wrong to
allow abortion all the way up to the
moment of birth they all had good
answers I thought desantis's answer here
was the best Nikki opens up and she says
you couldn't hear it totally In that
clip but you see her alluding to it
she's saying look we need some consensus
here we don't have enough Senators to
really stop abortion at the federal
level so we just we just need to work
together and find some consensus Maybe
it's 15 weeks maybe it's however many
weeks but let's just agree on this issue
and stop demonizing it Pence comes out
as the social conservative and says what
what are you talking about you know I
I'm a I'm a real pro-lifer you're not a
real pro-lifer Nicky I'm a real
pro-lifer and we need to be much tougher
on it and then Ron DeSantis comes out
and I felt he
melded Both Worlds and he seemed the
most sincere which is he said
look I just support life
and so I passed a law about it and I
have no regrets about that uh I'm I just
think we need to support life any way
that we can and I don't want to hear any
BS about well you can't make an abortion
law at the federal level it all has to
be at the state level I don't want to
hear that procedural nonsense and I
don't want to hear well we need to just
kind of reach a consensus and agree that
we can kill babies before this time but
not after this time I'm pro-life I'm
going to do whatever pro-life thing I
can do practically so he brings in the
Practical part that Nikki was trying to
talk about but he brings in the
principled and consistent part that my
Pence was talking about I thought it was
a good answer uh but it just faded away
rather quickly as once again the vague
steals the spotlight and gets into a big
spat with Mike Pence
what we really need is a tonal reset
from the top saying that this is what it
means to be an American yes we will
stand for the rule of law yes we will
close the southern border where
criminals are coming in every day and
yes we will back law enforcement because
we remember who we really are and that's
also how we address that mental health
epidemic in the Next Generation that is
directly leading to violent crime we're
not looking for a new national identity
the American people are the most
faith-filled Freedom loving idealistic
hard-working people the world has ever
known we just need government as good as
our people well Mike I think the
difference is you might have some others
like you may have on this stage it's
morning in America's speech it is not
morning in America we live in a dark
moment and we have to confront the fact
that we're in an internal sort of cold
cultural Civil War and we have to
recognize that people with the failed
government in Washington D.C we just
need government as good as our people
again and then Vivek goes on he says
look I don't know what that line even
means so I it's just that's just a line
that's recycled from the ray era and
just like your thesis you're trying to
say well it's really it's really morning
in America everything's hunky-dory we
just need to you know fix our attitude
or something and Vivek is saying no we
we're in a cold cultural Civil War he
didn't say this explicitly but I think
the implication is
there
killing babies their kids they're
arresting the opposition leader and his
lawyers and his supporters they're we're
not we're not in this happy moment let's
all just live up to our ideals we need
to make structural political change to
get back to a reasonable sense of
American identity this was purely a
generational divide I'm not saying one
guy one and one guy lost this fight I
think the boomers are going to be more
likely to favor Pence's view here and I
think the Millennials and the Zoomers
are going to be more likely to favor The
vivek's View I thought this was one of
the first
actual
generational conflicts that you've seen
on any presidential debate stage simply
because the candidates just keep getting
older and older and older so we haven't
seen that that
injection of millennial or obviously not
Zoomer Talent yet who makes 38 years old
so this is about as early as a
millennial could run for president but
that that is a big divide the Boomers
the silent generation they're still of
the belief that oh actually things
things are really okay we just gotta we
just gotta remember who we are and the
Millennials are saying man things are
not okay maybe they were okay when you
were grown up but there are some serious
issues that are not going to get better
by wishful thinking now when the
political order is all out of whack
you're going to want to protect your
assets you want to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 as
central banks in countries like China
India and Australia
begin transitioning to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
the digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze receives part or all of your
money these are some of the reasons that
concerned Americans reach out to Birch
gold
they want to have a physical asset like
gold that is independent of the US
dollar you can protect your IRA or 401K
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold historically gold has been a safe
haven in times of high uncertainty which
is right now learn if gold is right for
you too text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98 they will send you a free info kit
on gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on text Knowles Canada wlas to 9898 98
the question is was Vivek two Millennial
was Vivek II online was Vivek II focused
on campaigning to Twitter rather than to
the moderate American voter this became
especially clear on foreign policy when
Vivek came out against funding for
Ukraine
Mr Rama Swami you would not support an
increase of funding to Ukraine I would
not and I think that this is disastrous
sting against an invasion across
somebody else's border when we should
use those same military resources to
prevent across the invasion of our own
Southern border here in the United
States of America we are driving Russia
further into China's hands the
russia-china alliance is the single
greatest threat we face and I find it
offensive that we have professional
politicians on the stage that will make
a pilgrimage to Kiev to their Pope
zielinski without doing the same thing
for people in Maui or the south side of
Chicago or Kensington I think that we
have to put the interests of Americans
first if you're out on Border instead of
somebody else's okay and you hear Mike
Pence trying to interrupt there at the
end I actually kind of liked the Pence
interruptions because the knock on Pence
is that he's too boring and sleepy and
even if the interruptions became tedious
and were impolite they did show that the
guy was sort of fired up the consensus
view the neocon view the GOP
establishment view is that the American
people still love the war in Ukraine and
we want to support the war in Ukraine
the very online new right
emerging Millennial Zoom review is that
the war in Ukraine is a money pit these
foreign adventurers are pointless at
best and and harmful at worst and we
need to pull back from our Imperial
Ambitions overseas the fake is obviously
articulating that latter point of view
it comes down on Ukraine because both
sides point to poles to say that their
side is winning the the neocon types
will point to polls that when you ask
the American people ngip voters do you
support Ukraine in the war against
Russia they'll say yes overwhelmingly
but then the millennial Zoom review
which is we we don't really want to be
involved in Ukraine they'll point to
polls which which ask people do you want
to continue to fund the war in Ukraine
and the people overwhelmingly say no we
don't want to fund the war in Ukraine so
you're getting a little bit of a
conflict there both people are going to
point the this could be a real sticking
point in the election generally people
do not vote on foreign policy in
presidential elections but for the first
time in a long time you're seeing a
major fissure on the right among the GOP
not just with fringe candidates but with
mainstream candidates over the direction
of foreign policy this is because of the
election of trump
this is important I think why the
establishment hates him so much is
because for decades no matter which
party got elected they might disagree
over certain issues but they would
always agree on more migration they
would always agree on more free trade
and Outsourcing and they would always
agree on more war they would always
agree on more bombing of the same old
countries that both parties bomb and
Trump comes in and he says I don't want
to do that I don't want to build up
Empires overseas I don't want to keep
bombing the Middle East occasionally
I'll do it to tidy things up but I don't
want to get involved in nation building
and I think that and those two other
issues are a big part of the reason why
the establishment is going after him so
so hard it did become a big point of the
debate last night it was where Nikki and
Vivek both articulated their views the
best and probably both gained a little
bit among their base
is a murderer and you
and you a murderer
[Applause]
I love their border policies I love
their tough on crime policies I love
that they have a national identity and
an Iron Dome to protect their Homeland
and so yes I want to learn from the
friends that we're supporting and what
puzzles me yes
Israel wow that is an amazing line there
at the end so what Vivek is referring to
he says I love Israel's border policies
we should have those I love Israel's
immigration policies and Israel's strong
sense of natural national identity and
we should we should emulate that in
America we we also should have a sense
of national identity we also should have
strong borders and so he's clearly
pushing the the more new right foreign
policy the kind of foreign policy
articulated by Tucker Carlson the
foreign policy at least hinted at by
Donald Trump the foreign policy that
seems to be favored by younger
conservatives Zoomers and some
Millennials and it's not a new it's not
a new right foreign policy in that that
used to be the foreign policy of
conservatives that used to be the old
right that's the traditional
conservative foreign policy in the
United States by the middle to the end
of the 20th century the foreign policy
in the United States of conservatives
became a little bit more aggressive
interventionist wilsonian but that in
many ways what Vivek is talking about is
a return to an older more traditional
conservative type of foreign policy
Nikki is pushing a foreign policy that's
more typical of the last 20 30 years
often called The neo-conservative View
she comes in she says Israel doesn't
need America America needs Israel which
I think is a line she's going to come to
regret first of all because at least the
first part is not true Israel needs
America if America turn its back on
Israel that Nation would very likely
cease to exist now does America benefit
from the relationship of Israel
perhaps does America need Israel perhaps
one could even make that argument too
but this is the strongest view of this
nation-building overseas interventionist
State Department establishment foreign
policy and again that policy might
appeal to older GOP voters and older GOP
voters play a disproportionate role in
the primary process certainly over
younger voters but this this is the
reason why I think foreign policy could
be a point of condension here because
you're nesting among the mainstream
candidates a stark disagreement on
foreign policy and you've got because of
the war in Ukraine the prospect of the
the first major war in Europe since
World War II that the threat of of World
War III because you're dealing with a
proxy war between the global superpower
and a nuclear reformer superpower in
Russia this debate is not going anywhere
it's going to get far more intense so
you're going to want to prepare yourself
you're going to want to make sure you
eat a nice hearty meal you're going to
want to check out good ranchers right
now go to goodranchors.com use code
Knowles I don't know about you but this
summer heat in Nashville feels hotter
than a two dollar pistol you know
thanks to the Heat and the inflation
we're feeling the heat in more ways than
one the one thing that I'm not sweating
this hot summer is my meat price
thanks to good ranchers my price is
locked in for two years now you might be
thinking a price lock guarantee on meat
that's crazy as the price of meat
skyrockets well you're right it is crazy
I don't know why they're doing it it's
insane and I don't know how they're
going to make their money back
especially because good ranchers has the
absolute highest quality in the business
it's so freaking good there was I think
it was last week for dinner I had the
good ranchers Burgers which are the
juiciest most delicious burgers you've
ever had in your life and then for
breakfast I had steak and eggs sweet
little Elisa made it was a healthier you
know it was a sirloin it's not like I
was having a big fat ribeye but it's
just all of it the quality is so good I
can't get enough of it right now go to
goodranchers.com use code knowlescana w
l e s for 30 bucks off any box that is
promo code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered
our friend Candace just wrapped the
10-part series convicting a murderer
that you don't want to miss it is one of
the most ambitious projects yet you
might think that you are familiar with
the Steven Avery case and everything
that happened in Manitowoc County well
this is especially true if you watched
making a murderer but it turns out the
filmmakers only told you part of the
story coming soon Candace Owens will
unveil the shocking parts of Avery's
story that were omitted in the Netflix
series I'm so excited to present
the convicting a murderer trailer check
it out
in prison until DNA evidence
the two rivers man was convicted of
sexual assault in 1985 but exonerated
with DNA evidence in 2003. so this is
the infamous Avery lot now two years
later he again finds himself tied to a
police investigation accused of
murdering Teresa halbach on the Avery
property Steven Avery's 16 year old
nephew admitted his involvement in the
rape and murder of Teresa halbuck the
car is discovered just around the bed
was just this worldwide phenomenon I
think they framed this guy I think he
intended to crush the vehicle but ran
out of time Avery thinks the 36 million
dollar lawsuit he filed is why he's
being targeted in this investigation
[Music]
Netflix made millions of dollars from
making a murderer but the filmmakers
left out very important details
mountains of evidence that you have not
yet seen the blood vial the most
egregious manipulation from the movie
interrogations that's when he started
beating me because I told him that he's
sick cell phones and I saw melted
plastic parts of a cell phone interviews
her arms were pinned behind her head
they made Steven Avery look like a
victim you believe your brother is
guilty
I don't know if I'm a suspect I've been
online
I'm getting sick and tired of media
deception
evidence hiling off why would they omit
so many different things why are you
editing my testimony
I am not going to make the same mistake
that the filmmakers did
rearranging the testimonies the delete a
portion of it at the end how could they
claim to care about the truth they all
know that Steven Avery committed this
crime
everyone what's your emergency
the evidence forces me to conclude that
you are the most dangerous individual
ever to set foot in this courtroom
to get the rest of the story you got to
watch convicting a murderer coming to
you early September this 10 part series
is exclusive to daily wire plus so join
now at dailywire.com subscribe to get 25
off your new annual membership so you
can watch convicting a murderer when it
premieres trust me you don't want to
miss this all right last thing I want to
say about the debate then I want to move
on to the prosecutions and
some other things that are going on
maybe we'll get Jenna on the line
there was one moment in particular
that was really tough for the DeSantis
performance I thought DeSantis did fine
the problem is doing fine is not good
enough when you're down 40 points but he
did fine it's not like he blew himself
up on stage or anything like that he'll
he'll be at the next debate and he'll
have to hope that he doesn't lose too
much ground
there was one moment that actually
didn't go well for him in the moment
that didn't go well for him actively was
bad for him was when
the candidates were asked to raise their
hand if
they would support Donald Trump as the
Republican nominee if he were nominated
even if he was convicted of a crime in
court so this is a very dangerous
hypothetical no one on stage wants to
answer this
here's how it went down I'll describe it
for you if you're not watching if you're
just listening to the show
please raise your hand if you would
straight up followed by Nikki Tim Scott
bergam on the end
and some of the guys Mike Pence puts his
hand up eventually Christy puts his hand
half up ASA Hutchinson doesn't say
anything now I want play that clip again
because I want to focus now on the this
brutal moment for the the guy who's at
the center of the stage If This Were a
nine person race DeSantis would have
been dead center because it's an
eight-person race in the second tier
DeSantis and the Baker dead center and
you see the stark contrast the vague's
hand shoots up first thing Way High
DeSantis keeps his arm down looks at
Vivek sees that his hand went up and
then puts his hand up Governor at least
halfway
horrible look and and it's a horrible
look not because of the substance I
think DeSantis could have done well on
this question whether he raised his hand
or not he would have done better had he
raised his hand but even if he had kept
his hand down
the key to this answer was not the
substance of Are You Gonna
support Trump or not
the the key to the question is the
conviction
the key to the question was the speed
the confidence with which you did it
there's a line we were just talking
about Israel there's a line that a
Jewish friend of mine told me years ago
in Yiddish that I'm going to butcher the
Yiddish but I'll try it anyway I wrote
it down
Osman EST causer Zol s schenan e Baron
Moyle
which means it's probably you couldn't
even have that translated through some
kind of translation app my pronunciation
so bad what that line means is
if you're gonna eat pork eat it until
your mouth drips
if you're gonna do if you're gonna do it
do it if you're going to do something
that is transgressive if you're going to
do something that is dangerous if you're
going to do something that maybe you
shouldn't do but you then then do it at
least do it at least eat it until your
mouth drips okay and here you've got
something that candidates are not
supposed to do they're not supposed to
talk about supporting their rival in the
race they're not supposed to talk about
how they would let this guy get away
with a Criminal conviction and they
would still support him in the race
they're not they're breaking rules for
political candidates but the
circumstances of this question in this
unique primary campaign are such that
it does benefit them to say that they
will
support Donald Trump even if he's
convicted if he's the nominee they
signed the pledge and I guess Trump
didn't sign the pledge so maybe maybe
they can wiggle their way out of it but
they have
they're already doing it and so if
you're going to do it look strong about
it look like you're you have a view look
like you've thought about this thing so
vivek's Hand shoots right up in the air
it's that it's not even the hand it's
the look to Vivek was just seeding the
ground the hard one ground that DeSantis
has spent years as governor of Florida
making himself the alternative to Donald
Trump the leader in the race other than
Trump who's Far and Away the leader but
he's he's won that ground and he seeded
it last night and he seated it through
just kind of Fading Into the background
and letting other louder more talkative
candidates take the field
all of which is to say
uh I watched the Trump Tucker interview
love Tucker love Trump it's it was just
an interview you know you know that that
didn't move the needle at all but the
debate didn't move the needle either
which means that by default Trump wins
the night so I want to get to something
that's much more important than the
debate which didn't change anything I
want to get to something that might
change not only the 2024 election but
our entire political order something
that is so egregious that it represents
I think without hyperbole an actual
crossing of the Rubicon in the American
political order and it happens to
involve a friend of mine a personal
friend of mine along with a lot of other
people who don't deserve to be uh
persecuted in the way that they're being
persecuted the Liberals are rounding up
conservative dissidents and not just
excitable Midwestern grannies who walked
around the capitol rotunda on January
6th the worst day in the history of this
or any Republic no
they're they're not even just arresting
the leader of the opposition so insane a
former president so insane
they're arresting
his lawyers
just for
representing him for having the temerity
to provide legal representation to the
then sitting president of the United
States
that is for for making oneself a
dissident against the liberal
establishment regime
these people are now being arrested
including my friend Jenna Ellis who is
coming to us
Jenna first of all thanks for making the
time no you're busy we've been uh
praying for you obviously and following
this closely is I think this is the
first time you you're speaking since
you got out of jail
it is and thank you so much uh Michael
for your friendship and your prayers and
support this has been just an incredibly
insane experience to see that the left
is not only weaponizing government but
they're trying to criminalize the
practice of law
tell me everything that happened I what
before this is so serious that it's
either like you kind of laugh or cry I
mean it's so not even just because it
involves you but
I I just I never imagined this would
happen in the United States we talk
about political prisoners in evil
regimes Russia and communist China and
North Korea
you're a political prisoner you're out
on bond I will talk about that too but
you're you're a political prisoner as
simple as that I'm wondering which
nation is going to have more political
prisoners by the end of 2024. communist
China communist North Korea Putin's
Russia or good old USFA uh the the only
thing the only thing I'll say to make a
little light of it is our pal Mr Andrew
Clavin did say you have the most
beautiful mug shot ever in the history
of prosecutions but they they took your
mug shot
it it's it's so crazy and this is not an
America that I recognize and um you do
have to keep a sense of humor through
this but also realize the gravity of
this and and the reason that I smiled
yesterday was because the left wants to
see us miserable and crying like they
are because they have a false world view
they hate this country they want to tear
down our institutions of government they
want to tear down the constitutionally
protected right to obtain counsel they
want to tear down the practice of
lawyering and so I went in there simply
determined to say not today and I will
face this with resolve and I will face
this with the joy that I have in the
Lord in my faith and with the great a
Christian history and tradition of being
political prisoners of regimes and I am
um overwhelmed actually I never thought
in my lifetime I would stand shoulder to
shoulder with some of those who have
gone before me but um I actually have
this wonderful proof of incarceration
that I I was given that I'm going to
frame to show that you know this is
something that is very serious and so I
had to surrender yesterday in Fulton
County and I was taken back and you know
you see in in the jail and you see in
the movies kind of when they do that
walk um of Shame basically with all of
the other prisoners that are behind uh
bars and in the cells together like
clamoring and uh cat calling that
literally happened and so the woman who
took me back um and I won't mention her
name but she was incredibly kind I
thanked her afterwards because she stuck
by me the entire time that I was in that
jail with um I was taken into a place
that was just the general population
where there were other
um mostly men that were around that were
catcalling me that were saying vile
things and she said just look straight
ahead don't worry I will be right here
by your side the whole time and she did
her job and I respect her for that but
this is what um this has come to in the
United States of America that if you
were willing to as a lawyer give legal
advice and provide assistance of counsel
to the leader of the political
opposition then you too will become a
political prisoner and you will be
targeted and and so I spent uh the
afternoon in the Fulton County jail and
now have to report to pre-trial Services
be on Bond and they can control any
aspect of my life if I still want to
enjoy my freedom here in the United
States of America and if this is not the
biggest political issue that every
single GOP candidate should have stood
up strongly the debate last night and
said then they don't get what is
happening this is Way Beyond Donald
Trump yeah this is at the very heart of
American Liberties and freedoms and our
institutions I totally agree I can't
tell you I want to bang my head against
a wall when I've heard GOP commentators
and all the genius Consulting class they
say hey we've got to move on stop
talking about 2020 and January 6th and I
just let's just move on stop talking
about it they're rounding up the guys
lawyers they're rounding up GOP
activists who had the audacity to
question the most secure election ever
in the whole history of Elections going
back to Pericles give me a break if you
raise any question about that as the
liberals do every single time they lose
even if they lose by a country mile now
you could be arrested and
and lose your freedom as you say okay
you're out now you're out on presumably
a pretty pretty high Bond and it's a
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars yeah so where
what is the point of this so what what
is the point for the prosecution to put
you into a jail with a bunch of men
threatening you and Cat calling you what
is the point to take your hundred
thousand dollars what is the point I
guess it's just to humiliate you and
intimidate you and people like you
it's to set us up as an example to say
that if you want to stand against the
preferred Narrative of the government
then look at what happened to anyone who
is willing to stand with President Trump
and simply represent him have legal
theories and actually act as lawyers and
notice Michael that they're not doing
this to the lawyers who tried to use a
novel argument through the 14th
Amendment of that Marjorie Taylor green
a sitting congresswoman in Georgia uh
participated in a so-called Insurrection
there were lawyers that were that filed
a case and she actually had to go and
testify they ultimately did not Prevail
but no one is arresting them no one is
coming after their bar licenses for you
know trying to somehow interfere with an
election or you know overturn the
government in terms of her seat I mean
none of this ever applies to anyone else
and any of the leftist lawyers can have
any novel argument that they want to
write in the Atlantic they can say
anything that they want as long as it
goes with the regime's narrative but if
we stand up and actually say no we're
going to fight for Freedom we are going
to make sure to say that every legal
vote counts and counts fairly well then
somehow now that makes you a political
prisoner that makes you
um opposed to America fundamentally and
that makes you worthy of getting
indicted arrested and having to post a
100 000 bond in this country where are
you getting the money to a hundred
thousand dollars a lot of money
it is and thankfully there's a program
where I only had to put up 10 but still
I mean ten thousand dollars plus cost is
a lot uh and so thankfully you know that
was what I had to post but I am not an
independently wealthy person at all and
um interestingly the uh the Trump pack
the RNC none of these people who are
supposedly are friends and on the same
side are helping to my knowledge any of
us with any of these legal fees so I am
having to fundraise uh for myself and
they're thankfully God's people it's not
even just the political party God's
people and the Christians who understand
what persecution looks like they are
rallying to my defense and I have a
gifts and go it's Gibson togo.com
forward slash support Jenna and I've
raised as of now almost a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars I'm looking at
having to raise probably close to half a
million just to defend this which is
insane and ridiculous but I'm so
grateful for the Christians and the
conservatives who see that this is so
much bigger than who we support in a
presidential primary this is about the
very fabric of Freedom well that that of
course is the irony because obviously
you you were a lawyer for Donald Trump
to my knowledge you're not supporting
him in this Republican primary right so
it's not even like they're just going
after all the hardcore Trump acolytes or
anything like that they're going they're
going after people who support other
candidates they're going after
Republicans they're going after people
who to quote Alan dershowitz a liberal
who also worked as a lawyer for Donald
Trump who just support the Constitution
and they're gonna go get you anyway but
that's the point isn't it Jenna isn't
the point even if these charges are
completely bogus as obviously they are
well you're still going to be out half a
million dollars that might teach you
your lesson huh that might intimidate
some other people who might have the
gall to question the liberal regime
absolutely and that's why this is so
much bigger than Donald Trump or the
idea that this is just targeting him
this is not going to stop whenever
Donald Trump is done with politics this
is about and I stand with all of the
conservatives all of the pastors who
have been targeted with FBI raids with
all of the parents who are being put on
domestic terrorism watch list simply
because they have the audacity to
question what's in their child's state
funded School curriculum with all of the
Christians who uh like my dear friend
and former client Pastor John MacArthur
was threatened with jail time simply for
opening up his church and opposing The
covid Narrative I mean this is beyond a
political party this is all about
destroying fundamental freedoms and
Liberties in this country so we have to
as conservatives understand that bigger
picture that it is not about one
political candidate it's not about one
political party it is all about
opposition to the regime and if we do
not stand up now and understand what
they're doing then we are losing our
freedoms and when I was targeted for my
bar license by uh this democrat-funded
project they specifically went on media
and said the entire goal of this was to
destroy lawyers livelihoods reputations
and credibility they don't care that is
what they want to intentionally destroy
so what are the charges what what as far
as I can tell the crime you committed is
you just were a lawyer last I checked
every client in America not even just
the mean old orange man but even like
murderers and rapists and serial killers
everyone is entitled to Illegal defense
except for conservatives so what what is
the charge they're trying to get you on
right so they they indicted uh 19 of us
including former president Trump with uh
the RICO statute which is the organized
crime Enterprise uh racketeering statute
so uh we are all gangsters now
apparently
um allegedly according to the state of
Georgia and um then specifically I only
have one other count and there's some um
including president Trump have you know
I think he has something like 14 or 17
counts and all of this
um relates to at least for the lawyers
simply being lawyers and you don't see
any of this against the lawyers for
example from the bush Vigor case um I
think it was Alan dershwitz who said if
this same standard had been employed
back in the year 2000 when ultimately uh
Al Gore did not Prevail and they tried
to come after his lawyers in the same
fashion he said then I would have been
hit with a RICO violation and so this is
again it's just showing the double
standard
so they're saying that you're a mob boss
basically this is re has has the RICO
statute which I didn't know it could be
applied to anything other than organized
crime has this ever has this ever been
applied in in the way that we're seeing
it applied now to a politician's lawyers
not to my knowledge and uh and you're
right that the original intent of the
RICO statute was to prosecute organized
crime like drug rings and sex
trafficking and you know some of these
other um you know obviously really uh
violent crime that is a legitimate
function of government and so while I
can't really get into the specifics of
my own legal defense and I'm very
confident in my counsel uh what I can
say is that this is fundamentally
um taking and manipulating the law and
trying purposefully to apply it to a
scenario that lawyering clearly does not
fall into I mean if every Law Firm were
organized crime Enterprise simply
because they're representing their
client on legal challenges then we would
not have a practice of law or a right to
counsel but that's exactly what they're
targeting you know Jenna I'm glad that
you're confident in your in your Council
and I hope it's a great counsel but the
Democrats the Liberals always accuse us
of the things that they're doing and
never has this been clearer than in this
Rico nonsense the reason that I'm I'm
just a little worried for you I'm I'm
not worried in the sense that we trust
the Lord you know you do your best God
will do the rest what else can we do
Christians have danced and smiled while
they were fed to the Lions but in the
case of this this Rico prosecution
they are behaving like the mob they're
behaving like the five families in New
York and and the Mafia the way that
they're pushing people around and
intimidating people and acting in a
totally Lawless way and so I just fear
if they're willing to even bring these
Preposterous charges
how does one have any hope that justice
will prevail
well that's where I hope that we still
have America as we once knew it and uh
the America that was founded on the
principles of freedom and liberty and
opposition to tyranny and so if there is
any truth and Justice left in America
then I do believe that I will prevail
because I am innocent of these charges
but you're right uh Michael we've seen
throughout particularly church history
and Christian history that Justice in
this life isn't always accomplished but
that's why my faith in my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ is what is why I
still have joy because it is possible
that anything could happen we're not
guaranteed to Prevail even in a court of
law even when we are Innocent but that's
not what the Lord calls us to he calls
us to trust him have faith in him and
fulfill the Great Commission which is to
teach the truth of the gospel of Christ
throughout all the world and to stand
Resolute trusting in his sovereignty and
so that's what I am determined to do
through through this whole experience
that I could have never contemplated
would happen to me that come what may I
will trust in the Lord's sovereignty you
know Jenna can I can I keep you around
we've got I've gotta end the show here
for all the unwashed masses in the hoi
polloi we have a member block coming up
I know they're gonna have questions for
you I've got more I've got more
questions before we before we switch
over uh give send go.com support Jenna
that's where you can give to Jenna's
legal defense which I think is a really
great thing to do rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member at dailywater.com use
code Knowles check out for two months
free on all annual plans we will have
more with Jenna and your questions
coming up
foreign
[Music]